okay so i'm sorry what's your name again
my name is pastor troy pastor troy yes
sir tea leader great
i'm sorry t leader great also known as
pastor troy
excellent uh tell me uh tell me where
you grew up i grew up in oakland
california
tell me about childhood you had both
your parents as a kid more my childhood
a
single parent my mother raised me um my
father
was in the military and um came back and
unfortunately he was
messed up from the vietnam war so his
had a bad drug habit
so my mother raised me full time did
everything she could do she was a great
parent
how was your childhood my childhood for
the most part like i say
it was a typical childhood for a
black african-american male single
parent um
you know i didn't have everything that i
wanted but i had everything that i
needed
and for the most part i can't complain i
can say that i never
went with i went i never went without
yeah
other than your dad's drug addiction
seems like a pretty
yeah problem for you well it was a
problem at first growing up
because you know every young male needs
their father in their life and wants to
know where they are
but as i got older i kind of understood
you know the psychological
problem that he was going through from
being so far away from home
in the war so as i got older i kind of
accepted it
and it didn't bother me after probably
the age 12 or 13.
but before that yeah it was pretty tough
and then you got introduced to pimping
game at what age i got introduced to the
game
at first at the age of 19 years old and
you had role models around that showed
you
yeah for surely my role models was kenny
red he um
always always was the role model that i
looked up to
you know growing up and also hamp banks
out of san francisco
california filmo i looked up to those
guys you know they always
were the person that i seen i was having
all the money
had all the beautiful women and i kind
of gravitated to them
because them was the role models that i
wanted to be like so i kind of
soaked up the game and listened to
everything they had to give so how did
you get your first girl
i got my first girl at the age of 19
years old and
she was a girl that was in the
neighborhood little pretty little [ __ ]
you know she was in
not doing nothing with her life she just
liked to hang out smoke drink
and you know just be around she didn't
have nothing going on
so you know me being a young grasshopper
that i was at that point in time in life
i was just [ __ ] on her you know and
eventually i seen that happen she had
potential
to get some money because she was always
willing to have sex with multiple people
at the same time
so i introduced her to the uh game and
told her that she trusted believed in me
that i could show her how to get a whole
bunch of money and um
from there i just jumped off the diving
board how many girls did you have
eventually
at that point in time yeah and at that
point in time that was my first girl
yeah but the most girls i ever had at
one time was four
all stumped down straight laced all
one stable one house and how much of the
money do you keep
i keep everything you know i don't go
half with no [ __ ]
if i'm gonna give half of the money i'm
gonna give her half of my pimping so
guess what i don't do nothing have
so everything is always profit no splits
but i definitely make sure they get
everything that they need which they
want
what do they get they get everything
that they need that they want is
in order to continue to get my money
such as
you know a vehicle they need a vehicle
so they can go handle their business
they ought to fly his wardrobe that they
you know
got to stay fly to catch a trick eye
some money you know the bank account
they get whatever they need
something to take care of their family
you know whatever they need
if i feel like it's something that is
mandatory
it's no problem with getting it that's
why they're in the game for
have you in prison time definitely
what was the prison time for pippin and
pandering
living off the earnings and persuading
her persuading the witness
your girls are what races black white
hispanic at that point in time the girls
i was dealing with
two was black and one was mexican
and you have sex with the girls for
surely i have sex with the girls who
else i'm gonna have sex with
i'm not gonna go check my dick out with
a [ __ ] or
a square hoe that ain't doing nothing
for me if i'm having sex with any girl
it's gonna be the girl
that's in my stable that's in my life
that's making sure daddy got everything
they need
how do you handle a girl when she gets
out of line i mean you know
i'm not really with the uh own hands
gorilla pimping type and you know
that the world look at pimps do
you know i could use my mouthpiece and i
could break her down and make her feel
so small
but at the same time i could make her
understand the problems
that we're having because of what she's
doing you know so
at the most i ain't gonna say i've never
have put my hands on a [ __ ]
you know what i'm talking about but for
the most part i just chop them real bad
let them know what they're doing and
make them stand in the corner and put
their nose and
put their nose up against the wall
what's more important to you money or
love money
you ever been in love i definitely been
in love before when i was a young
grasshopper you know
high school adolescent days i definitely
wasn't loved
and i can't say i'm not in love right
now with a [ __ ] that i go outside every
day
who put her freedom on the line you know
who put her life on the line
that do whatever it take to make me
happy how can i not love somebody that's
doing that
that's a genuine love the laws have
changed since
uh since the old days the penalties are
much straight you know much
harder now is that charlie you're afraid
of uh
any of them in prison again well you
know and that's why i had to
take a step back and you know do
something else with my life because
right now
i so don't want to go back to prison
over dealing with the female
you know back then it was number to slap
on the wrist now they talk about human
trafficking
you know you're looking to have life
over dealing with a prostitute
that's been doing this longer than
you've been doing it and better yet
she has a resume of hohen in 50 states
50 cases but they want to blame the man
like they bring watching their [ __ ] to
do something
so once this start getting serious like
that and i did that for 16 months
i had to retreat man kick it back and do
something else man it's not worth it no
more
so you're you're no longer active right
now i'm no longer active you know
luckily i
was able to stack up enough money to do
what i needed to do in order
to take that money and do something
positive that was the reason why i'm in
the game
to take illegal chances to get some
money so that i could do something
legal with the money so you know i was
able to money launder and do something a
lot smarter now
would you specifically look for girls
that could steal from guys
i mean you know it's more than one way
very big to get some money you know
stealing is always a good thing you know
the rolex
the atm card you know however whatever
but
you know sometimes you can't steal none
or sometimes it's not a predicament so
if they can't steal it then there's more
than one way to get it
what's the craziest thing you've seen as
far as what like one of the what the
girls have had to do or what they've
done for
for money or anything about the game
that you've seen um
man i just seen some cold [ __ ] but um
i'm have to say i was in l.a on figaro
man
and then a [ __ ] got kidnapped
she got gang raped by five gangbangers
and they [ __ ] her in the ass with a
high heel
that's the craziest thing that i think
i've really really experienced in the
game man
and your kids definitely i have two are
you raising them
you know i'm co-parenting with the
parents
you have boys or girls i have one boy
and one girl what would you how would
you feel if your
son or daughter kind of followed in your
footsteps and like one of the girls
became
your daughter became a prostitute or
your son became a pimp
i mean one thing for sure you know
i wouldn't want my kids doing nothing
illegal to be in the streets
that's why i went so hard so that i
could give them the opportunity that
they didn't have to take no penetration
chances
but they was going to be in the game you
know i would just want them to know
really really know what they're doing
and what's the purpose of doing it
you know i can't say that i would be mad
and i can't say that i'd be happy it'll
just be something that i have to accept
you know it's a tough pill to swallow
but
hopefully they can get in and get out
you know and go on about eight minutes
and do something bigger or better
what's the most important lesson you've
learned doing this man the most
important lesson
i learned which the streets don't love
you
these [ __ ] is not faithful and they
only own you
for a moment that is not your [ __ ] yeah
i'm talking about that's just your [ __ ]
for the moment
and that you need to hurry up and get
some money and get up off the streets
man
because at the end of the day you're
gonna end up
chasing a little dream and end up
somewhere you don't want to be
so stay focused get what you're gonna
get
and get up out of it all right man well
thank you so much for sharing your story
yes sir and good luck with uh wherever
you go from here appreciate you man
thanks man thank you
i'm from california
you